Alice:收一下
Alice: Take it
Jake: 哎还是给我袋
Jake: Oh, still give me a bag
Jake: 我还是拿袋子
Jake: I'll still take a bag
Tasha: 不是说好一起收拾的吗
Tasha: Didn't we agree to clean up together?
Tasha: 可who在
Alice: 碍事
Alice: In the way
Jake:扔那吧
Jake: Throw it there
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay
Jake: 放架子上
Jake: Put it on the shelf
Jake: 架子上这个帮我挪一下啊
Jake: Help me move this on the shelf
Jake: 呃回头点再弄
Jake: Uh, I'll fix it later
Alice:嗯
Alice: Okay
Jake: 就这个板
Jake: Just this board
Alice:这个板
Alice: This board
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Alice: 私密马赛
Alice: Excuse me
Tasha: 哇大西不是故意的
Tasha: Wow, Daxi didn't do it on purpose
Alice: 哇大西不是故意的
Alice: Wow, Daxi didn't do it on purpose
Alice: 妈妈桑
Alice: Mama-san
Alice: 哈哈妈妈酱
Alice: Haha, Mama-chan
Alice: 我真的想戴上个手套说实话
Alice: I really want to wear gloves, to be honest
Tasha: 那可以戴那个无菌手套
Tasha: You can wear those sterile gloves
Tasha: 收拾
Tasha: Clean up
Shure:  完了你的福根被倒掉了
Shure:  你没有福了
Katrina:  哇菜刀
Katrina: Wow, a cleaver
Katrina:  给你舞一个
Katrina: Let me dance with it for you
Katrina:  这油倒哪呢
Katrina: Where should I pour this oil?
Tasha: 那
Tasha: There
Shure:  为什么拿他晒
Shure: Why are you sun-drying it?
Tasha: 我喝了
Tasha: I drank it
Tasha: 你好会扭哦
Tasha: You're so good at twisting
Katrina:  倒倒倒哪来的
Katrina: Pour, pour, where did it come from?
Shure:  我来倒吧
Shure: Let me pour it
Shure:  我来倒我来倒
Shure: I'll pour it, I'll pour it
Katrina:  倒麻酱里
Katrina: Pour it in the sesame sauce
Tasha: 对先倒到这吧
Tasha: Yeah, pour it here first
Katrina:  小时候我给老鼠做老鼠药就这样
Katrina: When I was a kid, I made rat poison like this
Shure:  还做这个呢
Shure: You made that?
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn
Katrina: 风油精花露水
Katrina: Essential balm and flower water
Katrina:  加一点好吃的饼干
Katrina: Add some tasty cookies
Katrina:  哎我看有没有那个塑料袋
Katrina: Hey, let me see if there's a plastic bag
Shure:  你觉得我
Shure: Do you think I
Shure:  我明天这瓶我觉得就可以喝完了
Shure: I think I can finish this bottle by tomorrow
Katrina:  哈哈哈再说你你就这样拿
Katrina: Haha, just take it like that
Tasha: 天呐噢
Tasha: Oh my god, wow
Tasha: 老板居然干最辛苦的活
Tasha: The boss is actually doing the hardest work
Jake: 确实
Jake: For sure
Tasha: 哎这个盆边好脏
Tasha: Hey, the edge of this bowl is so dirty
Jake:我去我这个油
Jake: Oh man, this oil
Jake: 好厚一层
Jake: Such a thick layer
Jake: 这个
Jake: This
Jake:先这么有用你你你来
Jake: First, you, you, you come here and be useful.
Jake: 这厨房水确实挺厉害
Jake: This kitchen water is really something.
Jake: 来您您来一起加加油吧
Jake: Come on, let's work together and keep it up.
Jake: 要不
Jake: Or else...
Jake:来来来来
Jake: Come, come, come.
Tasha: 来干活吧
Tasha: Let's get to work.
Tasha: 修硕
Tasha: Shure.
Tasha: 我教您
Tasha: Let me teach you.
Tasha: 您就把这个
Tasha: You just take this...
Shure: 我不听加油加油加油我不听
Shure: I'm not listening. Keep it up, keep it up, I'm not listening.
Shure:  加油加油哈哈哈
Shure: Keep it up, keep it up, hahaha.
Katrina:  你今天晚上任务是负责把
Katrina: Your task tonight is to...
Katrina:  yes OK
Katrina: Yes, OK.
Katrina:  学会明天教我们
Katrina: Learn it and teach us tomorrow.
Shure:  我我我今天晚上负负责喝的死死的
Shure: Tonight, I, I, I am responsible for drinking myself to death.
Shure:  然后睡觉
Shure: And then sleeping.
Katrina:  Lucy和儿子太像了呀
Katrina: Lucy looks so much like her son.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  酒精大学四年怎么过来的
Shure: How did I survive four years of college with alcohol?
Katrina:  哎苦学生
Katrina: Ah, poor student.
Katrina:  嘘又被我撞到了
Katrina: Shh, I bumped into it again.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈嘘
Katrina: Hahaha, shh.
Katrina:  大学四年都干什么啊
Katrina: What did you do for four years of college?
Jake:干哈呢
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:找找点活干
Jake: Find some work to do.
Jake:比如说把这些东西给扔掉
Jake: For example, throw these things away.
Choiszt: 这附近有大垃圾桶之类的吗
Choiszt: Is there a big trash can nearby?
Choiszt: 嗯
Choiszt: Hmm.
Jake:呃这个箱子留着
Jake: Uh, keep this box.
Jake:他们要当道具
Jake: They need it as a prop.
Jake: 是是大垃圾袋吗
Jake: Is it a big trash bag?
Jake: 是呗
Jake: Right.
Jake: 当然这边也用不着大垃圾袋
Jake: Of course, we don't need a big trash bag here.
Jake: 这边小垃圾袋足够
Jake: A small trash bag is enough here.
Jake: 那浪费浪费
Jake: That would be wasteful.
Jake: 那上去一会
Jake: Let's go up for a bit.
Jake: 上去再装啊
Jake: Go up and pack it.
Jake: 上来装
Jake: Come up and pack.
Katrina:  狂加醋
Katrina: Add a lot of vinegar.
Jake: 嘿卢亚呢
Jake: Hey, where's Luya?
Shure:  卢亚已经睡着了吧
Shure: Is Luya asleep?
Shure:  可能
Shure: Maybe.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:卢亚带个眼镜呗
Jake: Luya, wear some glasses.
Katrina:  他喝酒了吗
Katrina: Did he drink?
Shure:  他喝了一碗
Shure: He drank a bowl.
Jake: 一碗
Jake: A bowl?
Katrina: 完了
Katrina: Oh no.
Katrina:  哈哈晚上再来一局
Katrina: Haha, let's play another round tonight.
Katrina:  就直接给你掏心掏肺讲故事了
Katrina: He'll just pour his heart out and tell stories.
Shure:  哈哈哈我就要听掏心掏肺讲故事哎
Shure: Haha, I want to hear those heartfelt stories.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you.
Shure:  其实其实酒桌上掏心掏肺讲故事
Shure: Actually, at the drinking table, when you pour your heart out and tell stories,
Shure:  第二天第二另另外几个人都记不住
Shure: the next day, everyone else forgets.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Shure:  哈哈哈掏心掏肺讲完了你你很爽
Shure: Haha, you feel great after pouring your heart out, and so do the others,
Shure:  然后其他人也很爽
Shure: but no one remembers it.
Shure:  但是大家都记不住这个事
Shure: It just feels really good.
Shure:  情就很很很爽
Shure: You know?
Shure:  你知道吗
Katrina:  对爽了就行
Katrina: Yeah, as long as it feels good.
Shure:  这大家只走一个过程
Shure: It's all about the process.
Katrina:  真好呀主要我当时我舍友都特别乖
Katrina: That's great. My roommates back then were really well-behaved.
Katrina:  没人提议说去酒吧
Katrina: No one suggested going to a bar.
Shure:  也不一定非去酒吧呀
Shure: You don't necessarily have to go to a bar.
Katrina:  他们不喝
Katrina: They don't drink.
Jake: 这边都不够
Jake: This isn't enough.
Jake: 要不带点下去吃
Jake: How about we take some downstairs to eat?
Jake: 再带一个吧
Jake: Let's bring another one.
Jake: 碗下去洗吧要不
Jake: Take the bowl downstairs to wash, okay?
Jake: 这边够了
Jake: This is enough here.
Shure:  加油加油加油加油加
Shure: Come on, come on, come on, come on.
Alice: 这边这还有
Alice: There's still some here.
Choiszt: 呃等会你先别扔这个先把这个拿下
Choiszt: Uh, wait a sec, don't throw that yet, take this first.
Katrina:  什么cheerbaby
Katrina: What's cheerbaby?
Katrina:  就是他们在干家务的时候
Katrina: When they're doing chores,
Katrina:  你就在旁边cheer
Katrina: you just cheer for them.
Katrina:  babycheer
Katrina: Babycheer.
Katrina:  baby还会跳
Katrina: Baby can also dance.
Shure:  啊你也会跳这个是吗
Shure: Ah, you can dance to this too?
Katrina:  会啊高中的时候不是可流行的吗
Katrina: Yeah, it was super popular in high school.
Shure:  杨老板会跳这个吗
Shure: Can Jake dance to this?
Jake: 啥呀
Jake: What?
Shure: 在这个
Shure: This dance.
Shure: 好东西
Shure: It's awesome.
Jake: 哦会跳这个
Jake: Oh, I can dance to this.
Jake: 因为我我以前我在美国
Jake: Because back in the day, I was in the US.
Jake: 那个房东的小孩
Jake: The landlord's kid.
Jake: 就天天在我面前秀这个
Jake: He showed off this dance every day.
Tasha: 这个水是用这个是洗不掉的
Tasha: This water won't wash it off.
Jake: 那用什么
Jake: Then what should we use?
Tasha: 用他抹
Tasha: Use this to wipe it.
Tasha: 要吗
Tasha: Do you want it?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:要着
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Choiszt: 带个手套吧
Choiszt: Wear gloves.
Tasha: 哦我还以为你要把它装进来
Tasha: Oh, I thought you wanted to put it in here.
Choiszt: 也可以装进来
Choiszt: We can put it in here too.
Jake: 这个碗
Jake: This bowl.
Jake: 有多少是楼下的啊
Jake: How much of it is from downstairs?
Shure:  他虽然就是形态站在这
Shure: Even though he's standing here like this.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 这还有个男呃好吧他走了
Tasha: There's still a guy... oh, he's gone.
Katrina:  酒量测试开始
Katrina: Drinking test starts now.
Jake: 这要不放下面洗
Jake: Should we wash it downstairs?
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or...
Tasha: 就就在这洗吧
Tasha: Just wash it here.
Jake:就在这洗
Jake: Just wash it here.
Tasha: 你可以换一张抹布了
Tasha: You can use a new cloth.
Jake:还还能用
Jake: It still works.
Tasha: 这这这
Tasha: This, this, this...
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:错了错了错了
Jake: Wrong, wrong, wrong.
Jake: 哇确实
Jake: Wow, it's true.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 你确实
Tasha: It really is.
Jake: 你说的真的
Jake: What you said is true.
Jake: 那就是真的
Jake: Then it must be true.
Shure:  你干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure:  哈哈他妈的
Shure: Haha, damn it.
Tasha: 换一张吧
Tasha: Let's change it.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 我帮你扔掉
Tasha: I'll throw it away for you.
Jake: 谢谢您哎
Jake: Thanks a lot.
Shure:  不是我怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with me?
Tasha: 前天还好买了一包吧
Tasha: Good thing I bought a pack the day before yesterday.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 这个锅原来在二楼吗
Tasha: Was this pot originally on the second floor?
Lucia: 这个这个锅吗
Lucia: This pot?
Lucia: 嗯我也不
Lucia: Hmm, I'm not sure.
Lucia: 我也不太确定
Lucia: I'm not really sure.
Tasha: 没事我说以后不要在家做饭了
Tasha: Never mind, I said we shouldn't cook at home anymore.
Jake: 哦为啥
Jake: Oh, why?
Tasha: 洗碗这个活没有人愿意接受
Tasha: No one wants to do the dishwashing.
Jake: 确实
Jake: True.
Lucia: 那我把这个也放进去吧
Lucia: Then I'll put this in too.
Lucia: 跟你增加一点工作量
Lucia: Adding a bit more work for you.
Jake:好滴
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 这个是我的
Tasha: This is mine.
Tasha: 但是我没喝完嘛
Tasha: But I didn't finish drinking it.
Tasha: 好行
Tasha: Okay, fine.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Shure:  你喝吗啊
Shure: Are you drinking it?
Tasha: 我喝呢
Tasha: I'm drinking it.
Shure: 你真喝吗
Shure: Are you really drinking it?
Tasha: 真喝呢
Tasha: Really drinking it.
Tasha: 你喝一杯应该没关系吧
Tasha: It should be fine if you have a glass, right?
Alice: 醋放下边
Alice: Put the vinegar down there.
Shure:  我觉得就要给AI加一些不可控因素
Shure: I think we need to add some unpredictable factors to the AI.
Tasha: 可以竖着放
Tasha: You can put it vertically.
Lucia: 啊对不起对不起啊
Lucia: Ah, sorry, sorry.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: 刚那个有点使劲好像水崩起来了
Lucia: I think I pushed too hard, the water splashed.
Lucia: 没有溅到你们身上吧
Lucia: It didn't splash on you, did it?
Jake: 好油啊
Jake: So greasy.
Tasha: 没关系这只是洗第一
Tasha: It's okay, this is just the first wash.
Tasha: 遍还有洗第二遍的
Tasha: There's a second wash.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 好油啊
Tasha: So oily.
Tasha: 你看这个
Tasha: Look at this.
Tasha: 原本是很干净的杯子
Tasha: It was a very clean cup.
Tasha: 你把它放到油碗里
Tasha: You put it in the oil bowl.
Tasha: 好油呀他变的呵呵
Tasha: It's so oily now, haha.
Jake: 擦完就扔洗碗机了一般
Jake: Usually, I just wipe it and throw it in the dishwasher.
Tasha: 你怎么不购入一台
Tasha: Why don't you get one?
Tasha: 买一个小碗洗碗机吧
Tasha: Buy a small dishwashing machine.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 我们有硕
Jake: We have Shure.
Alice: 还有垃圾吗
Alice: Any more trash?
Tasha: 硕硕
Tasha: Shure.
Jake: 来一轮
Jake: Come on.
Tasha: 没了
Tasha: No more.
Tasha: 没了嗯
Tasha: No more, yeah.
Lucia: 这个可以当垃圾袋用
Lucia: This can be used as a trash bag.
Shure:  what's up bro
Shure: What's up bro?
Tasha: 让你买个洗碗机
Tasha: I told you to buy a dishwasher.
Jake:让你当个洗碗机
Jake: I told you to be a dishwasher.
Tasha: 让你当个洗碗机
Tasha: I told you to be a dishwasher.
Shure:  让我买个洗碗机
Shure: You want me to buy a dishwasher.
Jake: 买个是难
Jake: Buying one is hard.
Tasha: 让你当一个洗碗机
Tasha: I told you to be a dishwasher.
Jake:当个洗碗机
Jake: Be a dishwasher.
Jake: 当个洗碗机
Shure:  我靠买个洗碗机
Shure: Damn, buy a dishwasher.
Shure:  真的吗bro
Shure: Really, bro?
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 堵住了你有没有发现需要您清理
Tasha: It's clogged, haven't you noticed? You need to clean it.
Tasha:我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Tasha: 这筷子洗的
Tasha: These chopsticks are washed.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha: 我去真有水平
Tasha: Wow, impressive.
Shure:  跟洗跟没洗的一样
Shure: It's like they haven't been washed at all.
小薇 你看他这个筷子洗的
Tasha: Look at these chopsticks.
Tasha: 洗成两坨了
Tasha: They're in two pieces now.
Shure:  哎呦卧槽
Shure: Oh, damn.
Jake: 跟没洗的一样
Jake: Just like they haven't been washed.
Shure:  一看就是在家
Shure: Obviously, they are at home.
Shure:  一天天娇生惯养的孩子们
Shure: Kids raised in comfort and luxury every day. 社会问题
Jake: 可拉倒吧
Jake: Oh, come on.
Jake: 谁在家呢
Jake: Who's at home?
Shure:  请问在在Singapore
Shure: Excuse me, in Singapore.
Shure:  娇生惯养的孩子
Shure: Pampered kids.
Jake: 那也没在在Singapore也不在家待着
Jake: Even if they're not in Singapore, they're not staying home.
Shure:  哎我搅一会吧
Shure: Ah, let me stir it for a bit.
Shure:  然后先让他水流下去
Shure: Then let the water flow down first.
Jake:我这先搁哪呢
Jake: Where should I put this?
Shure:  你随便搁哪都行
Shure: You can put it anywhere.
Shure:  然后我搅一会就行
Shure: Then I'll stir it for a bit.
Shure:  你别搁搁地漏上就行
Shure: Just don't put it on the drain.
Jake: 我先去洗洗手去
Jake: I'll go wash my hands first.
Shure:  哎愁死了
Shure: Ah, this is so frustrating.
Jake: 你们再收拾收拾你们哈哈哈
Jake: You guys tidy up a bit, hahaha.
Jake: 啊啊你们收拾收拾
Jake: Yeah, tidy up.
Jake: 我们要扫这个整个屋子了
Jake: We need to sweep this whole room.
Choiszt: 这个屋要扫
Choiszt: This room needs to be swept.
Jake: 要这这个屋要扫扫要
Jake: Yes, this room needs to be swept.
Jake: 不用收就客厅
Jake: No need to tidy up, just the living room.
Jake: 客厅我们稍微收拾收拾
Jake: Let's just tidy up the living room a bit.
Jake: 规整规整
Jake: Make it look neat.
Jake: 一副能让能扫的样子
Jake: So it looks like it can be swept.
Jake: 没事一会他们会进去
Jake: It's okay, they'll come in later.
Choiszt: ;这个包什么的
Choiszt: What about this bag?
Jake:呃对对
Jake: Uh, right.
Jake: 对这个不是我的
Jake: This isn't mine.
Jake: 先放这吧
Jake: Just put it here first.
Jake: 一会让他们收一下
Jake: We'll let them clean it up later.
Choiszt:  这个这个是花的
Choiszt: This, this is a flower.
Nicous: 这什么东西啊
Nicous: What's this?
Jake:这个硬盘用的扔了扔了
Jake: This hard drive, throw it away.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 晚上不太好扫
Jake: It's hard to sweep at night.
Jake: 就
Jake: Just...
Jake:那个你视野扫的里
Jake: Sweep wherever you can see.
Jake:再仔细的扫一遍
Jake: Then sweep carefully again.
Jake: 3dinstead
Jake: 3D instead.
Jake: 晚上扫一下白天扫一下啊
Jake: Sweep once at night and once during the day.
Jake: 我我先把我屋子收一收
Jake: I'll tidy up my room first.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 哎不是你这这不能扔
Jake: Hey, no, you can't throw this away.
Jake: 这是这确实是买的
Jake: This was definitely bought.
Jake: 确实是特地买的
Jake: It was bought on purpose.
Jake: 特地买的
Jake: Bought on purpose.
Jake:啊呃不是
Jake: Ah, uh, no.
Jake:路亚应该昨天伤着
Jake: The lure probably got damaged yesterday.
Jake: 擦破了什么的
Jake: Got scratched or something.
Jake: 你你上去有那个厨房纸他比较好
Jake: You, you go upstairs, there's some kitchen paper, it's better.
Jake: 上面有那个厨房纸他
Jake: There's kitchen paper upstairs.
Jake: 有点牛逼
Jake: It's pretty awesome.
Jake: 这个扔出去吧这
Jake: Throw this away.
Jake: 这还有一堆纸
Jake: There's a bunch of paper.
Jake:呃有有可能有用
Jake: Uh, it might be useful.
Jake:留着擦一擦
Jake: Keep it to wipe things.
Jake: 我靠确实挺牛逼啊你们
Jake: Wow, you guys are really amazing.
Jake: 既然这屋子应该长这样卧槽
Jake: So this room should look like this, damn.
Jake: 牛逼
Jake: Awesome.
Katrina:  却又消失不见
Katrina: Yet it disappeared again.
Katrina:  明天干什么呀
Katrina: What are we doing tomorrow?
Shure:  杨老板我们什么时候扫房间啊
Shure: Jake, when are we cleaning the room?
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Katrina: 明天干什么
Katrina: What are we doing tomorrow?
Jake:明天
Jake: Tomorrow.
Shure:  扫房间扫房间扫房间
Shure: Clean the room, clean the room, clean the room.
Jake: 今晚扫一遍明天扫一遍
Jake: Clean it tonight, and again tomorrow.
Jake: 现在收拾完就开始扫
Jake: Once we're done tidying up, we'll start cleaning.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 然后那个交换礼物
Jake: And then we'll do the gift exchange.
Shure:  你告诉我这是什么我给你放
Shure: You tell me what this is, and I'll place it.
Katrina:  明天干啥嘞
Katrina: What are we doing tomorrow?
Jake:明天干啥嘞
Jake: What are we doing tomorrow?
Jake: 明天室外吧
Jake: Outdoors tomorrow.
Jake: 明天整点室外
Jake: Let's do something outdoors tomorrow.
Shure:  KTV吧
Shure: How about KTV?
Jake:可拉倒吧
Jake: No way.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  这附近好像有一个最近的公园
Katrina: There's a park nearby, I think.
Katrina:  是两三公里
Katrina: It's two or three kilometers away.
Katrina:  你要去公园吗
Katrina: Do you want to go to the park?
Jake: 可以去采一采景拍拍东西
Jake: We can go shoot some scenery and take some pictures.
Jake: 然后最后一天放
Jake: And then on the last day, we'll...
Katrina:  最后一天放
Katrina: On the last day, we'll...
Jake:放放放影片
Jake: We'll screen the film.
Katrina:  最后一天放影片
Katrina: Screen the film on the last day.
Jake: 对这个采采风吧
Jake: Yeah, let's go capture some scenery.
Katrina:  就是明天户外是吧
Katrina: So it's outdoor tomorrow, right?
Jake: 对明天户外
Jake: Yeah, outdoor tomorrow.
Jake: 采采风对
Jake: Capture some scenery, yeah.
Jake: 明天主要是等快递啊
Jake: Tomorrow is mainly about waiting for the delivery.
Katrina:  啊快递有好多才今天下的
Katrina: Ah, a lot of deliveries were just placed today.
Jake: 对明天
Jake: Yeah, tomorrow.
Jake: 明天等快递
Jake: We'll wait for the delivery tomorrow.
Jake: 在路上后天你们快递
Jake: On the way, the day after tomorrow, your deliveries...
Jake: 到了才能再setup吧
Jake: Once they arrive, we can set up.
Lucia: 这是不是可以用来洗那个啥
Lucia: Can this be used to wash that thing?
Katrina:  其实快递的集中应该是在后天到
Katrina: Actually, the bulk of the deliveries should arrive the day after tomorrow.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake:是是
Jake: Exactly.
Katrina:  你买时钟了吗
Katrina: Did you buy the clock?
Jake:我买了
Jake: I bought it.
Katrina:  那明天就一个户外
Katrina: So tomorrow is just outdoor.
Katrina:  不允许这么宽泛的存在
Katrina: It can't be this vague.
Katrina:  你们当时那个表呢
Katrina: Where's that watch you had?
Katrina:  好吧略胜一筹啊
Katrina: Alright, a slight advantage.
Shure:  哈哈哈这叫略胜吗
Shure: Hahaha, you call that a slight advantage?
Shure:  哈哈哈碾压
Shure: Hahaha, it's a total domination.
Jake: 什么呀
Jake: What?
Katrina:  他说我的那个平板音响跟他的那个
Katrina: He said my flat speaker and his...
Jake: 哦哦哦略胜一筹
Jake: Oh, a slight advantage.
Katrina:  开外挂
Katrina: Cheating.
Choiszt:  他们压花是压这个花是吗
Choiszt: Are they pressing this flower?
Jake:哎不是嗯
Jake: Uh, no, um.
Jake:哎确实是
Jake: Uh, actually yes.
Choiszt: 那这个不是要开七天吗
Choiszt: Isn't this supposed to be open for seven days?
Jake:呃对
Jake: Uh, yeah.
Jake: 这个会放在每个人卧室里面
Jake: This will be placed in each person's room.
Jake: 然后就拍呗
Jake: And then you can take pictures.
Jake: 每个人都能拍到就是
Jake: Everyone can take pictures.
Tasha: 歇会吧
Tasha: Let's take a break.
Jake: 最后压好像是最后压最后压还是怎么样
Jake: So, the last compression seems like it's the final compression, or how does it work?
Choiszt: 这是谢冰竹电脑
Choiszt: This is Xie Bingzhu's computer.
Jake: 明天在外边
Jake: Tomorrow, we'll be outside.
Choiszt:  ：应该是day3是吗
Choiszt: It should be day 3, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Choiszt: 啊刚刚day3
Choiszt: Oh, just now was day 3.
Jake:其实可以不是就是出去
Jake: Actually, it could be, just going out.
Jake:哎户外户外拍短片嘛对
Jake: Yeah, shooting a short film outdoors, right.
Jake:就大概是这样大概是
Jake: That's basically it.
Jake: 户外拍短片拍这么一天
Jake: Shooting a short film outdoors for a day.
Jake: 然后星期五差不多他们快递
Jake: Then on Friday, their package should arrive.
Jake: 星期五星期六他们快递到了
Jake: Friday or Saturday, their package will arrive.
Jake: 然后什么排舞什么的
Jake: And then, you know, arranging the dance and stuff.
Jake: 呃对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:啊对这两天就比较集中吧
Jake: Oh right, these two days will be pretty packed.
Jake: 然后这一天就开始了
Jake: Then that day will start.
Jake: 所以明天其实就是出去拍拍片
Jake: So, tomorrow is basically just going out to shoot the film.
Choiszt: 他们那个快递是要整理装饰房间的
Choiszt: Their package is for organizing and decorating the room.
Jake:嗯对快递应该星期五才能到吧
Jake: Yeah, the package should arrive by Friday.
Choiszt:  OK
Choiszt: OK.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 哈喽
Jake: Hello.
Lucia: 哈喽
Lucia: Hello.
Tasha: 就只剩两个锅了
Tasha: There are only two pots left.
Alice: 还有一个池子
Alice: And one sink.
Jake: 还有一个池子
Jake: And one sink.
Alice:用威猛先啊啊生
Alice: Use Mr. Muscle first, ah.
Jake: 是要泡一会吗
Jake: Do we need to soak it for a while?
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or...
Alice:池子用这个就行了
Alice: Just use this for the sink.
Alice: 有威猛先生
Alice: We have Mr. Muscle.
Jake:哦这么威猛吗
Jake: Oh, is it really that powerful?
Lucia: 因为那锅好像放不进来
Lucia: Because the pot doesn't seem to fit.
Jake:哦就是准备泡一泡是吧还是啥
Jake: Oh, so we plan to soak it, right? Or what?
Jake:锅放不进来
Jake: The pot doesn't fit.
Jake: 那锅能擦干净吗
Jake: Can the pot be cleaned?
Lucia: 这个应该不能洗锅这只能洗
Lucia: This can't be used for the pot, it can only clean...
Jake:哦哦哦那锅就
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, so the pot...
Lucia: 现在现在洗洁精好像在楼下是吧
Lucia: Now, now, the dish soap seems to be downstairs, right?
Alice: 他为什么连个喷头都没有啊
Alice: Why doesn't it even have a spray head?
Jake:就这个光擦能擦明白吗
Jake: Can you really clean it just by wiping?
Lucia: 看是
Lucia: We'll see.
Lucia: 当然也可以勉强这样子一下
Lucia: Well, we can barely manage it like this.
Lucia: 就就是他对不太准
Lucia: It's just not very accurate.
Lucia: 那个什么
Lucia: What's that...
Lucia: 擦咱能把它擦明白吗
Lucia: Can we really clean it thoroughly by wiping?
Jake:试试
Jake: Let's try.
Alice:洗洁精在下面
Alice: The dish soap is underneath.
Jake: 是
Jake: Got it.
Shure:  什么and啊
Shure: What "and"?
Shure:  我教你and怎么写啊啊
Shure: I'll teach you how to write "and".
Katrina:  啊sorry啊sorry
Katrina: Oh sorry, sorry.
Katrina:  啊有点那个
Katrina: I'm a bit...
Katrina:  才疏学浅
Katrina: Lacking in knowledge.
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Oh my!
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Katrina:  一下高级了起来哎
Katrina: Suddenly it feels sophisticated.
Jake: 压花要压多久
Jake: How long do we press the flowers?
Shure:  半小时
Shure: Half an hour.
Katrina:  什么东西
Katrina: What?
Jake: 压花要压多久
Jake: How long do we press the flowers?
Jake: 压花
Jake: Press the flowers.
Katrina: 压花压花要压两天
Katrina: We press the flowers for two days.
Katrina:  没有没有
Katrina: No, no.
Katrina:  你做了然后再放那放两天
Katrina: You do it, then leave it for two days.
Jake: 就是明天得压
Jake: So we press tomorrow?
Jake: 明天压半小时
Jake: Press for half an hour tomorrow.
Jake: 然后放那放两天是吗
Jake: Then leave it for two days, right?
Katrina:  压花随时随地可以压
Katrina: You can press flowers anytime.
Katrina:  我就是手上闲了我就可以压
Katrina: I can press them whenever I have free time.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  就把它摘下来放那就行了
Katrina: Just pick them and leave them there.
Jake: 好那就
Jake: Alright then.
Katrina: 这就是我自己弄着玩的啊
Katrina: This is just something I do for fun.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina: 先扫房间吗
Katrina: Should we clean the room first?
Jake:嗯扫一遍就是边扫
Jake: Yeah, clean it once, just clean while...
Jake:扫的话
Jake: While cleaning...
Jake: 那你们得躲着我
Jake: You all have to avoid me.
Jake: 对就是
Jake: Yeah, just...
Jake: 你要不没电了
Jake: Maybe you're out of power.
Jake: 要不你没删
Jake: Or you didn't delete it.
Shure:  哦我没删
Shure: Oh, I didn't delete it.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 你还没导吧
Shure: You haven't imported it yet, have you?
Jake:导了
Jake: I have.
Jake: 全倒完
Jake: It's all done.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 我现在要扫
Jake: Now I need to scan.
Jake: 然后扫房间
Jake: Then scan the rooms.
Jake: 然后我不能扫到人
Jake: I can't scan people.
Jake: 看到我就要躲
Jake: If you see me, you have to hide.
Katrina:  那我们待一楼呗
Katrina: Then we'll stay on the first floor.
Katrina:  你先去扫二楼可以
Katrina: You can scan the second floor first.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  是那天扫我们人体的那个机器吗
Katrina: Is it the machine that scanned our bodies the other day?
Jake: 不是就是iPhone
Jake: No, it's just an iPhone.
Katrina:  哦好
Katrina: Oh, okay.
Shure:  先去吧
Shure: Let's go then.
Katrina:  哇世界地球日的这个
Katrina: Wow, the Earth Day thing.
Jake: 然后你们可能在下面聊聊
Jake: Then you guys might chat downstairs.
Jake: 那什么
Jake: About what?
Katrina: 明天计划
Katrina: Tomorrow's plan.
Jake: 对明天在户外
Jake: Yeah, tomorrow, outdoors.
Jake: 原来是可以
Jake: Originally, it was possible.
Jake: 就是最后世界地球日
Jake: It's the last Earth Day.
Jake: 投影上面放点
Jake: Put something on the projector.
Jake: 你们
Jake: You guys...
Katrina: 徒手画圆
Katrina: Freehand drawing a circle.
Katrina:  画这地球
Katrina: Drawing the Earth.
Jake: 秀点照片影片什么的
Jake: Show some photos or videos.
Jake: 在外边对
Jake: Outside, yeah.
Jake: 采风就是采风
Jake: It's just a field trip.
Jake: 然后最好有个剧本
Jake: And it's best to have a script.
Jake: 但是很难
Jake: But it's hard.
Jake: 所以就随便拍拍得了
Jake: So just shoot whatever.
Jake: 挺圆是是个圆
Jake: It's pretty round, it's a circle.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina: 我数学老师当时那个叫什么
Katrina: My math teacher back then, what was his name...
Alice:那我下去拿吧
Alice: Let me go get it.
Tasha: 在那个冰箱上
Tasha: On that fridge.
Jake: 擦完了
Jake: It's wiped clean.
Lucia: 没有这个要纯粹用它擦干净太难擦了
Lucia: No, it's really hard to clean it thoroughly with just this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 我把那边那个
Lucia: I took care of that side.
Lucia: 这大概花了三四张纸然后擦出来的
Lucia: It took about three or four sheets to get it clean.
Lucia: 虽然比刚开始干净多了
Lucia: Although it's much cleaner than before,
Lucia: 但是没有那个啥那么干净
Lucia: it's still not as clean as it could be.
Lucia: 看看
Lucia: Take a look.
Jake: 我现在要扫一遍房间
Jake: I need to sweep the room now.
Jake: 但是可能也不是现在
Jake: But maybe not right now.
Jake: 我在想什么时候扫比较方便
Jake: I'm thinking about when would be the best time to sweep.
Lucia: 我已经收拾的差不多了
Lucia: I've already tidied up most of it.
Jake: 好哦嗯
Jake: Okay, got it.
Jake: OK行
Jake: Alright, sure.
Tasha: 然后我们要干嘛
Tasha: So what are we doing next?
Jake: 你们在下面聊聊
Jake: You guys chat downstairs.
Jake: 礼物你们怎么互送抓阄还是
Jake: How are you going to exchange gifts? Drawing lots or...?
Lucia: 我都可以我是一个什么都可以的p人
Lucia: I'm fine with anything, I'm pretty easygoing.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Tasha: 我想不到好的办法
Tasha: I can't think of a good way.
Lucia: 大家有什么idea吗哈哈
Lucia: Does anyone have any ideas? Haha.
Jake: 摇骰子吧
Jake: Let's roll dice.
Tasha: 谁大谁先挑
Tasha: Whoever rolls the highest picks first.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Katrina: 挑啥呀
Katrina: Picks what?
Tasha: 挑礼物摇骰子
Tasha: Picks gifts, we'll roll dice.
Alice:挑礼物
Alice: Picks gifts.
Lucia: 鉴于我的礼物是个小choker
Lucia: Since my gift is a little choker,
Lucia: 所以我认为男生如果抽到的话
Lucia: I think if a guy gets it,
Lucia: 并没有什么
Lucia: it's not really...
Tasha: choker
Tasha: A choker?
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha!
Jake: 这样吧你们下去聊聊明天的计划
Jake: How about you guys go downstairs and discuss tomorrow's plans?
Tasha: 明天干嘛
Tasha: What's happening tomorrow?
Jake: 对明天户外
Jake: Yeah, outdoor activities.
Tasha: 户外
Tasha: Outdoor?
Jake: 户外采采风
Jake: Outdoor excursion.
Tasha: 采什么风
Tasha: What kind of excursion?
Jake: 拍拍照片
Jake: Taking some photos.
Jake: 玩一玩
Jake: Let's play around.
Tasha: 这样吗
Tasha: Like this?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 游客照吗
Lucia: Like tourist photos?
Tasha: 野餐吗
Tasha: A picnic?
Jake: 呃最后一天可能放点短片什么的
Jake: Uh, maybe on the last day we'll show some short clips or something.
Jake: 其实
Jake: Actually...
Jake: 原来想要有一个剧本结果好像也没有
Jake: Originally, I wanted to have a script, but it seems like we don't.
Jake: 什么剧本
Jake: What script?
Lucia: 不是您不是有个剧本吗
Lucia: Didn't you have a script?
Jake:不是
Jake: No.
Tasha: 您不是有个备用剧本吗
Tasha: Didn't you have a backup script?
Tasha: 那要不我们现在找一个剧本
Tasha: How about we find a script now?
Tasha: 然后我们开演吧
Tasha: And then we can start acting?
Tasha: 对就这种只需要本性出演即可
Tasha: Yeah, just something that requires natural acting.
Lucia: 你知道韩国有一个
Lucia: You know in Korea, there's a...
Lucia: 就是类似于哔哩哔哩上面那种小
Lucia: It's similar to those short clips on Bilibili.
Lucia: 短片的那么一个团队
Lucia: They have this team...
Lucia: 他们是就是
Lucia: And they...
Lucia: 既然我们最近几天
Lucia: Since we've been...
Lucia: 一直在讨论MBTI的事情
Lucia: They've been talking about MBTI.
Lucia: 就他们是就是就是一直在做一些就是
Lucia: Like, they keep doing these, like, um...
Lucia: 呃通
Lucia: Uh, you know...
Lucia: 就是这种MBTI的这种小情景短剧
Lucia: These little MBTI skits.
Tasha: 小什么
Tasha: Little what?
Lucia: 就是情景短句
Lucia: Like, little skits.
Lucia: 就是比如说比如说你是假设你是你是
Lucia: For example, if you pretend you're a J-type person
Lucia: 你是j人
Lucia: and I'm a P-type person,
Lucia: 然后我是p人
Lucia: and we're discussing something,
Lucia: 然后我们俩比如说在讨论某个问题
Lucia: then a J-type might generally have a certain opinion,
Lucia: 然后就是j人可能就是呃呃
Lucia: and a P-type might have a different one.
Lucia: 大概率会有什么什么样的看法
Lucia: Yeah, like, most likely.
Lucia: 然后p人
Lucia: And then P-type...
Lucia: 大概率会有什么什么样的看法
Lucia: would most likely think something else.
Lucia: 对就是但是他是以一种就是
Lucia: But it's not super rigid or academic.
Lucia: 不是那么很刻板和学术
Lucia: There's a context to it.
Lucia: 他确实会有一个语境
Lucia: Like, for example,
Lucia: 比如说啊
Lucia: ah...
Lucia: 我们三个围在一起吃火锅啊什么的
Lucia: we're sitting around eating hotpot or something,
Lucia: 然后突然聊到什么问题
Lucia: and then we suddenly start talking about something.
Lucia: 然后比如说就是
Lucia: So for example...
Lucia: 就是因为
Lucia: It's because...
Lucia: 比如说那个今天的月亮好圆啊
Lucia: For example, the moon is so round tonight.
Lucia: 不是表白的时候经常用的一句话吗
Lucia: Isn't that a common line for confessions?
Lucia: 或者什么
Lucia: Or like...
Lucia: 我想跟你看今天的月亮怎么怎么样
Lucia: I want to watch the moon with you tonight.
Lucia: 然后就是如果是t人的话
Lucia: And if it's a T person...
Lucia: 就会觉得啊
Lucia: They might think...
Lucia: 为什么要说这句话
Lucia: Why would you say that?
Lucia: 然后如果是f人的话
Lucia: But if it's an F person...
Lucia: 就会很快get到
Lucia: They'll get it right away.
Lucia: 然后觉得啊好浪漫什么的这种
Lucia: And think, oh, that's so romantic.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Tasha: 那就是按聊天
Tasha: So it's like chatting.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 就是如果有
Lucia: If we have...
Lucia: 比如说有类似的这样的剧本的话
Lucia: For example, a script like that.
Lucia: 我们可以按照他随便演一下
Lucia: We can just act it out casually.
Lucia: 就
Lucia: Like...
Lucia: 如果我们实在找不到什么别的XTV剧
Lucia: If we really can't find any other XTV scripts.
Jake: OK其实也不用我
Jake: Actually, we don't need to...
Jake: 我就觉得就是
Jake: I just think...
Jake: 可能就是最后一天放点背景墙
Jake: Maybe on the last day, we can just put up a background wall.
Jake: 上面放点照片得了
Jake: And put some photos on it.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 也可以啊
Tasha: That works too.
Tasha: 我以为是要演电视剧
Tasha: I thought we were going to act out a drama.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 就是这种有剧情的短片
Jake: Like those short films with a plot.
Jake: 如果有的话就可以
Jake: If we have any, we can.
Jake: 其实就是世界地球日
Jake: Actually, for Earth Day...
Jake: 可能这个迎接的时候可能放点PPT
Jake: We could just show some PPTs.
Jake: 放点电影
Jake: Show some movies.
Jake: 放点短片这种
Jake: Show some short films.
Jake: 然后明天可能就在户外玩一玩
Jake: And then tomorrow, we could do some outdoor activities.
Jake: 拍一拍拉倒了对
Jake: Just take some videos, and that's it.
Lucia: 是想拍一个vlog之类的吗
Lucia: Are you thinking of making a vlog or something?
Jake: 可以是
Jake: Could be.
Jake: 那要不每人拍个vlog得了
Jake: How about everyone makes a vlog?
Jake: 其实就是拍点户外的素材
Jake: Just shoot some outdoor footage.
Jake: 你们在户外
Jake: You guys are outdoors
Jake: 可能也会有一些奇怪的activity
Jake: There might be some strange activities
Jake: 就是室内
Jake: It's indoors
Jake: 就不是室内的activity吧
Jake: It's not indoor activities
Jake: 就是可能在河边走走啊
Jake: Maybe just walking by the river
Jake: 就就是做点素材吧
Jake: Just creating some content
Jake: 就是就我也不知道干什么
Jake: I don't really know what to do
Jake: 就是多拍照
Jake: Just take more photos
Jake: 然后最后能放到最后一天就行
Jake: And we can use them on the last day
Jake: 在最后一天能够呈现
Jake: We can present them on the last day
Jake: 然后能演到今天就行
Jake: And that's enough for today
Lucia: 所以我们最后一天到底需要有一个
Lucia: So on the last day, do we need to have a...
Lucia: 不是您指的这个剧本是什么意思
Lucia: What do you mean by this script?
Lucia: 是我们这些天的活动的一个一个剧本
Lucia: Is it a script for our activities these days?
Lucia: 然后在最后一天呈现吗
Lucia: And then we present it on the last day?
Lucia: 只不过现在把这个idea pass掉了
Lucia: But now we're just passing this idea around
Jake: 哦呃
Jake: Oh, uh
Jake: 对没有任何的剧本
Jake: Yeah, there's no script
Jake: 就是
Jake: It's just...
Lucia: 不是我一般以为team Lidar都是一个j
Lucia: I usually think team Lidar is a...
Jake: 哈哈哈因为这个就很火
Jake: Hahaha, because it's really popular
Jake: 本身就是一个
Jake: It's actually a...
Jake: 叫什么生活类数据集
Jake: What's it called, a lifestyle dataset
Jake: 对爱干啥都行
Jake: So you can do whatever you want
Jake: 最后只要能联系上就行
Jake: As long as it connects at the end
Tasha: 爱睡觉行吗
Tasha: Is sleeping okay?
Jake: 就得动起来
Jake: You have to be active
Tasha: 哦爱打游戏行吗
Tasha: Oh, is playing video games okay?
Jake: 那你得一边
Jake: Then you have to...
Jake: 你得跳着舞打
Jake: Dance while you play
Lucia: 健身环哈哈哈
Lucia: Fitness ring, hahaha
Tasha: 健身房里面玩金铲铲啊
Tasha: Playing "Golden Shovel" in the gym?
Lucia: 没有我说的是switch那个健身环
Lucia: No, I meant the fitness ring on the Switch
Lucia: 哦不过健身房里玩也可以啊
Lucia: Oh, but playing in the gym is fine too
Tasha: 买
Tasha: Buy
Lucia: 跑步机哈哈哈
Lucia: A treadmill, hahaha
Jake: 对明天就
Jake: Yeah, tomorrow just...
Tasha: researcher
Tasha: Researcher
Tasha: 在这里哈哈
Tasha: Over here, haha
Jake: 嗯好research
Jake: Mm, good research
Jake: OK research
Lucia: 我们有个地点吗
Lucia: Do we have a location?
Lucia: 周围有啥
Lucia: What's around?
Jake:对有个公园
Jake: Yes, there's a park.
Lucia: 公园
Lucia: A park?
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 有多大呀能玩一天吗哈哈哈
Lucia: How big is it? Can we spend the whole day there? Haha.
Lucia: 我想了想户外
Lucia: I was thinking about outdoors.
Lucia: 还可
Lucia: It's fine.
Tasha: 会被晒黑吧
Tasha: We might get tanned, right?
Tasha: 就喜欢公园能玩一天吗
Tasha: Just like the park, can we spend a day there?
Lucia: 我觉得这这么小的
Lucia: I think in such a small...
Lucia: 村子应该
Lucia: Village, it should...
Lucia: 公园不是很大
Lucia: The park isn't that big.
Lucia: 所以我们可以在公园里面再来一次
Lucia: So we can do another ice-breaking game in the park.
Lucia: 破冰游戏
Lucia: Ice-breaking game.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:也可以啊
Jake: That works too.
Tasha: 既然大家都是研究生了
Tasha: Since we are all graduates...
Tasha: 那我们就玩一些
Tasha: Let's play something...
Lucia: 那我们就互相研究研究研究
Lucia: Then let's research each other.
Lucia: 哦还可以
Lucia: Oh, still good.
Katrina:  我们开始扫了吗
Katrina: Have we started cleaning?
Jake: 对可以扫
Jake: Yes, you can clean.
Jake: 是刚刚说什么研究生
Jake: What was just said about graduates?
Lucia: 飞花令
Lucia: Poetry game.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Jake: 害怕
Jake: I'm scared.
Katrina:  明天的游戏吗
Katrina: Is this for tomorrow's game?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 对明天再再琢磨整点啥
Jake: Yes, let's think about what to do tomorrow.
Lucia: 用古诗词飞吗
Lucia: Using ancient poems?
Lucia: 还是飞什么
Lucia: Or what else?
Katrina:  古诗词我不行
Katrina: I'm not good with ancient poems.
Tasha: 不然用什么飞
Tasha: Then what else to use?
Katrina: 第一个就死了
Katrina: I'll be out on the first round.
Katrina: 第一轮就死
Katrina: First round, I'll be out.
Katrina:  我的房间已经收拾好了
Katrina: My room is already cleaned up.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 比如不出来
Lucia: For example, not coming out.
Katrina: 我看一下我们去那个地方
Katrina: Let me check that place we're going to.
Tasha: 我就想问问扩展到哪些领域了
Tasha: I just want to ask which fields it has expanded into.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 就是好像现在也没有原来那么传统
Lucia: It seems like it's not as traditional as before.
Lucia: 就是比如说
Lucia: For example,
Lucia: 刚开始不是只有一
Lucia: At the beginning, it was just one thing.
Lucia: 比如说就是花字带花字的
Lucia: Like, with floral patterns.
Lucia: 后来就变成什么什么意向的
Lucia: Later, it became something more conceptual.
Lucia: 或者说描述啥啥的
Lucia: Or descriptive.
Lucia: 哦哦哦不过
Lucia: Oh oh oh, but.
Tasha: 行啊
Tasha: Alright.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 挺好一会呃
Jake: Pretty good, in a bit, uh...
Jake: 一会就是我要扫房间
Jake: In a bit, I need to sweep the room.
Jake: 然后你们可以
Jake: Then you guys can...
Jake: 我先扫楼上
Jake: I'll sweep upstairs first.
Jake: 然后你们可以先下楼去讨论
Jake: Then you guys can go downstairs to discuss.
Jake: 然后我扫楼下的时候你们再上来啊
Jake: When I sweep downstairs, you guys can come back up.
Tasha: 就是不能有人是吧
Tasha: So no one should be around, right?
Jake:就是我的
Jake: Yeah, in my phone's range, no one should be there.
Jake: 手机的范围里面不能有人
Jake: My phone's range should be clear.
Lucia: 扫之前跟我说一声
Lucia: Let me know before you start sweeping.
Lucia: 因为我要把那边挂两件衣服拿出去
Lucia: Because I need to take out two pieces of clothing hanging there.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 那我要不然我还能挂着两件湿衣服不习惯
Lucia: Otherwise, I don't like leaving two wet clothes hanging.
Jake: 对对对那两件可能就哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah yeah, those two pieces, haha...
Jake: 这就相当于是
Jake: It's like...
Jake: 这个屋子里边固有的财产了
Jake: They have become part of the room's fixed assets.
Lucia: 哈哈哈就把它拿出来
Lucia: Haha, just take them out.
Lucia: 然后就就就基本上只剩下箱子和包了
Lucia: Then, basically, only the boxes and bags are left.
Lucia: 别的我都塞进去了
Lucia: I've packed everything else.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 啥呀这是
Jake: What is this?
Katrina:  给他女朋友买礼物挑的头疼
Katrina: He's having a hard time picking a gift for his girlfriend.
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake: 你你怎么了
Jake: What's wrong with you?
Jake: 你你女朋友怎么了
Jake: What's up with your girlfriend?
Katrina:  没怎么
Katrina: Nothing much.
Katrina:  就是一个平板
Katrina: Just a tablet.
Jake: 就开心是吧
Jake: So, she's happy, right?
Jake: 就是一个开心
Jake: It's just for fun.
Jake: 开心就买是吧
Jake: Buying if it makes you happy, right?
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Oh my God.
Jake:我要我要开扫了
Jake: I'm going to start scanning.
Jake: 要不我先扫下面
Jake: Or should I scan downstairs first?
Shure: 快扫快扫
Shure: Quick, scan quickly.
Jake: 上去吧
Jake: Go ahead.
Jake:你们你们得上去
Jake: You guys, you guys need to go up.
Jake: 下面那是空的啊
Jake: Downstairs is empty.
Choiszt:  需要人手吗
Choiszt: Do you need any help?
Jake: 这个不需要人手
Jake: This doesn't need help.
Shure:  不需要人是空的
Shure: No help needed, it's empty.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 呃可以可以你在我旁边
Jake: Uh, okay, you stay beside me.
Jake: 然后我这个
Jake: Then, this...
Jake: 我这一层扫了之后
Jake: After I finish scanning this floor...
Jake: 然后我会躲在一个地方
Jake: Then I'll hide somewhere.
Jake:让他们
Jake: Let them...
Jake: 就就是
Jake: Just...
Jake: 比方说你是这么扫我
Jake: For example, you scan me like this...
Jake: 这这这个
Jake: This, this...
Choiszt:  你不洗一下
Choiszt: Aren't you going to wash up?
Jake: 问题不大问题不大
Jake: It's not a big deal, not a big deal.
Jake: 哦你要给我一个
Jake: Oh, you want to give me one?
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 是这样的
Jake: It's like this.
Jake: 这样就是呃你先跟他们说
Jake: So, you tell them first...
Jake: 扫都扫你你你先
Jake: Scan, scan, you first...
Jake: 你先上去跟他们说
Jake: You go up and tell them first.
Jake: 让他们先去讨论个明天的方案出来
Jake: Let them come up with a plan for tomorrow first.
Jake: 然后下来下来
Jake: Then come down, come down.
Jake: 你跟他们讲我跟他们讲吧
Jake: You tell them, I'll tell them.
Jake:就是一会的扫描活动都在吗
Jake: So, is everyone ready for the scanning activity later?
Jake: OK一会的扫描活动就是我在下面扫
Jake: Okay, for the scanning activity later, I'll be scanning downstairs.
Jake: 然后我下面扫完之后
Jake: And after I finish scanning downstairs...
Jake: 呃我会躲在一个房间里面
Jake: Uh, I'll hide in a room.
Katrina:  然后我们去找你
Katrina: Then we'll come find you.
Jake: 然后我为了不扫到人
Jake: So I don't scan people.
Jake: 所以说我会在里面待着
Jake: That's why I'll stay inside.
Jake: 然后我让刘帅下来叫你们
Jake: Then I'll have Choiszt come down to call you guys.
Jake: 然后但是我不能扫到你们对吧
Jake: But I can't scan you guys, right?
Jake: 嗯所以说你们也要躲在一个房间里面
Jake: So you guys also need to hide in a room.
Jake: 就你们得躲在就你们就躲在
Jake: You need to hide, just hide.
Jake: 你们就在你们就室外吧
Jake: Just stay outside.
Jake: 好吧好对
Jake: Okay, right.
Choiszt: 一楼扫完了他们不都去一楼都可以去一楼
Choiszt: After the first floor is scanned, they can go to the first floor.
Jake: 就是我上楼的时候不能扫到人
Jake: I can't scan anyone while I'm going upstairs.
Jake: 我上楼的时候你们在
Jake: While I'm going upstairs, you guys are...
Jake: 对对对对嗯
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, right.
Jake: 然后你们在这就聊一聊明天的安排吧
Jake: Then you can talk about tomorrow's plan.
Katrina:  嗯那你就躲在一个
Katrina: Hmm, then you hide in a...
Choiszt: 反正我叫他们下去他们就下去藏好
Choiszt: Anyway, when I tell them to go down, they will hide.
Jake: 对你们就你们
Jake: Yes, you just...
Jake: 就就就出门就好
Jake: Just go out, it's fine.
Jake: 你们也可以
Jake: You can also...
Jake: 现在在外边都都行
Jake: Now stay outside, it's all good.
Jake: 总之就是我不能扫到人
Jake: The point is I can't scan anyone.
Jake: 你们聊一聊啊
Jake: You guys chat.
Jake: 明天安排多多
Jake: Discuss the plan for tomorrow.
Jake: 多交流多交流
Jake: Communicate more.
Jake: 多交流
Jake: 反正明天大概是就是就是在户外
Jake: Anyway, tomorrow's plan is mostly outdoors.
Jake: 然后加点压花什么的对吧
Jake: And add some pressed flowers, right?
Jake: 这个
Jake: This...
Jake: 多说话啊多说话
Jake: Talk more, talk more.
Jake: 抓一大充电宝
Jake: Grab a big power bank.
Choiszt: 扫还是用那天那个软件扫是吗
Choiszt: Are we still using that app to scan?
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake:这是要密度很高的扫
Jake: The scanning needs to be very thorough.
Jake:然后不能扫到你
Jake: And I can't scan you.
Jake: 你得一直在我后面就是makesure啊
Jake: You need to stay behind me to make sure.
Choiszt:  那你转手机你也得跟我说一声
Choiszt: Then you need to tell me when you turn your phone.
Jake: 这当然我我会转的很慢很慢
Jake: Of course, I'll turn it very slowly.
Jake:合上吧放到一个好位置
Jake: Close it and put it in a good spot.
Jake:然后你上去
Jake: Then go upstairs.
Jake: 这个你让你让客厅得收拾收拾
Jake: You need to tidy up the living room.
Jake: 就上面得是一个特别好的状态
Jake: The upstairs needs to be in perfect condition.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 开始了
Jake: Let's start.
Jake:我靠我得扫到这个是吧
Jake: Damn, I have to sweep this, right?
Jake: 看怎么躲
Jake: Let's see how to dodge.
Jake:你你你诶我我我我从这个地方
Jake: You, you, you, hey, I, I, I, I'll go from here.
Jake: 对对对你现在不要出来对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, don't come out now.
Jake: 我让你出来也再出来
Jake: I'll let you out when it's safe.
Choiszt:  你扫这镜子怎么办呀
Choiszt: What if you sweep this mirror?
Jake:我我在呃没关系
Jake: I'm, I'm, uh, it's okay.
Jake: 我有独特的扫镜子技巧
Jake: I have a unique way of sweeping mirrors.
Jake: 等一下我这扫的很
Jake: Wait a second, I'm sweeping this very...
Jake:很全面
Jake: ...thoroughly.
Jake: 这个门开着
Jake: This door is open.
Jake: 哎人呢来玩吧
Jake: Hey, where is everyone? Come play.
Jake: 确实挺好玩
Jake: It's really fun indeed.
Choiszt: 我现在应该可以站到厨房这块
Choiszt: I should be able to stand in the kitchen now.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 嗯没问题
Jake: Hmm, no problem.
Jake: 可以
Jake: It's fine.
Jake: 呃扫了但是回头还是要把它去p掉
Jake: Uh, I swept it, but we'll still need to edit it out later.
Jake: 这东西有点牛逼
Jake: This thing is pretty awesome.
Jake: 神尼玛运镜卧槽
Jake: Amazing camera work, damn.
Jake: 绕了一圈没关系
Jake: Went in a circle, it's okay.
Jake: 哎呦卧槽槽槽
Jake: Oh crap, crap, crap.
Jake: 躲着啊躲着躺下
Jake: Dodge, dodge, lie down.
Jake: 你你到后面去
Jake: You, you go to the back.
Jake: 可以让他们出去
Jake: We can let them go out.